denn hätte es kommt nichts bei mir im
november zu einem neuen video leute wir
haben uns gedacht welchen trend gab es
dennoch nie auf youtube ein trend war
der tropfen kommen wir machen einen
wirklich video und zwar durch wir haben
auf max ist kann es kemkers kanal und
auf meinem kanal ist der behörden ihm zu
weit
heute ist von der drohung für drogen
vollgedröhnt wer bin ich bei max gibt es
video blogger sind in der beschreibung
verlinkt und jetzt schreibe die zettel
und legen los ist prinzip kennt man
anders schräger erkennst dafür wissen
wir nicht funktioniert meine ängste
zähler auf den kopf oder muss man
milliarden ein fragen daten der mann
leiterin sektion video gesagt dass emc
auf 5 da mein geschäft nahm der könig
was man gemacht hat deine augen auf der
ersten zettel
ich war für dich jetzt sogar al jazira
okay wir waren also z
ich hoffe sie kann man das erkennen
können wie komme ich aus einem land
komme ich aus einem land ja ja ich habe
es 40 abhängig aber deutschland mache
ich deutschsprachige videos komme ich
aus deutschland österreich gehört nicht
zu deutschland das wisst ihr auch
ehrlich dann daheim österreich das holen
was spanien als vollendet haben ihre
wurzeln die länder überdies zwei euro
fragen leute als man dazu ab ostern bei
jenen kanals und jede dann hab ich über
50.000 abos nein doch nicht
privat im deutschsprachigen videos nein
ich komme nicht aus doch schön
ich mache ich englischsprachige videos
habe ich über eine million abonnenten ja
ich habe fünf bilder oder moment nein
das weiß was das jetzt sagen wollte
meine frage hab ich schon mal game ich
auf meinem kanal gemacht ich glaube ich
habe ich hängen die sprache video worden
ja alles was nicht deutsch ist es
eigentlich schon englisch gemacht zum
beispiel gegen ein video habe ich über
eine million ab jetzt schwierig ja er
habe ich über sieben millionen
ich habe zwischen einer million und fünf
millionen abonnenten mache englisch wie
das mache ich gaming geben
wir hatten sich kennt sexleben ja okay
dann sich die frage ist solche nachricht
kam mit nein wo nicht auch in
deutschland ja wohl nicht in nrw obwohl
ich in köln
er wohne ich in köln in einer wg mit
anderen menschen nein diese runde ist
richtig dass blogs mache ich eher so
mein eigenes ding und lade zu videos
sowie beispielsweise okay heute neu
beauty blablabla oder halt mache ich
eher so also das ist jetzt kann ich ja
nein fragen oder was genau bezieht sich
mein content auf aktuell polarisierende
themen
ja ja ja komm ich aus amerika habe ich
eine freundin kann und so bin ich mal
archiv jetzt habe ich mich auf das aber
wirklich kennt nicht die person die
ärztin youtube-kanal unter 5000
abonnenten habe ich schon mal musik
gemacht auf einem kanal
ich glaube er nicht mehr braucht bin ich
da bin ich unter 30 glaube nicht nein du
gehst nicht unter 30 bin ich unter 30
hörer ist nein nein es wird meist gaming
habe ich auch mal die auf einem kanal
gemacht hast du auf deinem körper
mitmacht blogs da habe ich mal lux
gemacht ja ja ja
hat einer von uns schon mal mit dieser
person ein video zusammen gemacht max
die ja max hat schon ein video mit der
person gesagt ja ich fand das ist ja
alle nicht gesagt nicht beantworten aber
ich habe auch schon mal wieder mit der
person machte rechnet bin ich vor kurzem
nach köln gezogen definiere vor kurzem
wieder als letzten halben jahr nein nein
das definitiv mittag mache ich musik hat
dann ja man kann schon sagen dass musik
muss nichts weiter tun als über googles
während knapp aber ich würde eher sagen
kein komme die bürger häufig zu
erreichen ist das scheiß christen kommt
nicht dran
was ist so ist wir können nicht männlich
ja ja ja ich war mir erst nicht sicher
aber damit ist noch geschockt mache ich
teilweise diss tracks auf meinem kanal 5
millionen es ist immer dieselbe scheiße
man denkt man das irgendwo bei der habt
ihr schon mal mitgemacht
ja also ich wusste einfach nicht mehr
dieses video im jahr 2016 oder
vorgemacht 2015 vor
so genau weiß ich nicht auf jeden fall
2016 oder vor 25 ihr könnt ja auch schon
alle gleich
oder aktionäre die schon gemacht aber
irgendwie schade gerade die videos die
wir mit ihnen gemacht haben 2016 oder
davor dass ihr euch gerne person aus
denke mir fällt niemand eigentlich doch
mal drauf kommen ich bin ja ein bisschen
frech deswegen gegeben habe aber schon
bei den habe ich blonde haare
was ist hier erwartet ja ja ja ja das
ist durchaus gefunden als auf deiner ich
hoffe dass wir 2 sgb v ist noch eine 1
bin ich von den junggesellen ein was für
mein video wird das verkehrskonzept hier
schon so und dann
wer sich musik ist hier bild alter wie
mich meine freunde nicht gesehen sagt
sie so wenig problem kommt spart jetzt
erste frage ich das schon so scheiße war
bedeutet ist komplett falsch
nein ich mich immer leute wenn ihr euch
denken komplett hinüber liegen was soll
die scheiße das video wird alles erklärt
also erstmal wird auch nicht vergessen
weil ich wenn ich oder weil sie sagt das
leben ganz kurz mit ich bin ein
männlicher youtuber aus amerika kommt
aus der westküste aus amerika ist küssen
das kenne ich diesen kanal safe ja mach
ich blogs nein nicht jetzt habe ich mich
ja erst das habe ich die person schon
mal getroffen und ich würde sagen ja
würde sagen ja oder habe ich mir schon
mal getroffen hat es los und ich schon
mal getroffen sind blogs der
hauptbestandteil von einem kanal will
ich als frau die jetzt aktuell bekannt
für dich
jetzt hilft bei dir dein kanal dreht
sich größtenteils um das was aktuell
passiert also größtenteils um aktuelle
thema was interessiert bin ich die
franco ich habe ewig gefühl ich bin ich
bin ich selbst fast so eine dumme
ergebnis ein gutes gefühl habe ich über
300.000 abonnenten nicht über 300.000
weiter erfolglos war sie am anfang zu
machen sagen wollte das ist okay ich
habe wirklich noch nie mehr in die
gaming gemacht hat nein habe ich von
anderen kanal schon immer gern gemacht
[ __ ] berühren dies ist der dritte
keine wahlhilfe hat egal hilfe weil man
die blogs in kreuth 3 kanal von einem
youtuber ich bin zeigt ja in zwei kleine
familie in köln wo ja ja und da hat ja
und auch alleine ganz am anfang
das war es von dem video leute ich habe
mich so kaputt gelacht dass ich einfach
komplett das auto vergessen habt schickt
auf jeden fall die folgen von den
anderen beiden ab es war so fucking
lustig hier könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren hier kommt jetzt in einer
neuen folge von was es geht von
unitymedia chip ist gern mal ab dessen
wie der frische vollmilch am start das
irgendwann meine lustiges video seit
langer zeit was gut